[Musique]
messieurs bonjour nous vous recevons
aujourd'hui pour une chaîne Youtube qui
s'appelle servview on aurait aimé avoir
un petit peu votre expérience sur
l'actualité et sur des sujets de fond on
va commencer par vous présenter à ma
gauche nous avons Hervé Brusini qui a
été rédacteur en chef du journal de
France 2 deux fois de suite de fois 2
ans et la dernière fois vous avez quitté
c'était en 2011 vous êtes actuellement
directeur du site franc tv.info et vous
avez reçu le Prix Albert lde pour
l'affaire farwellmi un dossier sur
farwell nous avons à notre centre Pierre
conessa ancien des Affaires stratégiques
qui a qui est passé un petit peu sur la
vente d'armes des des choses comme ça et
des des expertises au niveau du
Moyen-Orient et nous avons un autre
droite bonjour Éric Filiol qui est
directeur d'un laboratoire de virologie
de cryptologie informatique qui est
ancien officier de la DGSE messieur
bonjour Pierre connaissa bonjour comment
on est arrivé là les attentats de Paris
et toute cette folie autour de la
ceinture
méditerranéenne le bon on peut remonter
à c'est loin mais enfin bon on va
essayer de la faire brève
euh il faut il faut évidemment reprendre
la la chose au moins au moment de ce de
cette erreur stratégique gigantesque qui
a été l'invasion de l'IRAC par les
néoconservateurs américains c'est
explicatif de deux chose d'abord le fait
qu'il y a un mou il y a une espèce de
idéologie politique qui est aujourd'hui
malheureusement très répanu en France
qui s'appelle néoconservatisme et qui
pense que on peut redessiner la carte du
globe par des moyens militaires et le
point d'application de cette politique
ça a été l'invasion de l'Irak et
l'invasion de l'Irak a donc commencé la
à générer une pagaille absolument
extraordinaire sur cet espace
géographique euh et puis ensuite il y a
eu le choc des révolutions arabes qui
s'était répandu en Syrie donc on a une
espèce de de dialectique où il y a les
dynamiques internes du système et puis
les dynamiques externes des des
décideurs occidentaux qui continuent à
considérer que le l'espace
moyen-orientale est un espèce de terrain
de jeu pour nos militaires puisqu'ils
passent leur temps à en voyer des
militaires partout Hervé
moi je pense que c'est la première fois
que j'arrive à la télé c'est le je
dirais le massacre de la rue des rosiers
et là on était de dans devant une
composante
palestinienne qui était celle
d'abounidal sinistre personnage
et je me souviens qu'à l'époque on était
en mal d'expliquer les choses
euh le journalisme était convoqué
à la nécessité de faire une pédagogie de
la
situation et là il a fallu ouvrir un peu
les livres d'histoire se remuer et pas
simplement faire la revue de la violence
et c'est là que la première fois moi je
m'en j'avais pas croisé ça en
classe j'ai vu cette expression qui est
les accords saxpico c'est ce truc des
années de post prère guerre qui dessine
la carte du
Moyen-Orient et très souvent c'était
écrit à quel point c'était quand même
assez
artificiel et donc je pense
que depuis cette époque nous ne cessons
de
payer une situation
géopolitique qui a
été comment dire une du prix c'est ce
quiexlique je trouve assez
remarquablement luizard dans un appelle
le piège daesh qui est que on a fait
croire à beaucoup de des populations
locales que on allait célébrer une sorte
de grande unité arabe et on s'est
ingénié à faire tout le contraire et
c'est ce que disait pierre c'est-à-dire
qu'il y a effectivement cette ce
rapport très militaire très c'est nous
qui décidons à votre place et quelque
part l'astuce de daesh c'est de dire
c'est nous les vrais représentants de
des aspirations qui sont les vôtres et
donc faut nous rejoindre ça passe à la
fois par la mise en l'air des frontières
qui ont été dessinées ils ont fait ça en
2014 à coup de buldozer pour montrer que
voilà cet ancien ordre n'était plus
valable et bien sûr le le le califat et
tout ça avec une violence absolue parce
que ces populations en même temps
n'aspirit pas vraiment à ça directement
mais néanmoins garder ce souvenir fort
d'une identité arabe Éric Filiol moi je
pense que surtout le la conséquence est
le résultat d'une méconnaissance totale
de des cultures et et surtout l'idée
qu'il existerait qu'un seul modèle le
nôtre applicable à à l'ensemble du monde
euh et justement cette idée est fausse
parce qu'elle elle s'inscrit dans une
méconnaissance une ignorance grass de ce
que sont les cultures alors qu'il
pendant alors le mot va peut-être
choquer mais pendant 200 ans
d'expérience colonial on avait des
militaires qui au contraire euh
s'adaptaient aux cultures locales les
comprenaient et finalement essay de
trouver un compromis qui était en faveur
d'ailleurs des populations locales on
est passé à un modèle euh très centré
sur l'Europe et sur le modèle anglosaxon
en pensant que ce modèle unique est
force est valable pour tout le monde et
doit s'imposer à tout le monde or quand
on connait bien les cultures et c'est
justement le un problème actuel c'est
que on ne comprend plus ces cultures
alors qu'ell soit de cette région là
mais en général dans d'autres parties du
monde et en fait bah c'est une faillite
de cette de cette vision pierre connais
ça bah je crois que l'essentiel a été
dit c'est-à-dire
effectivement ce rapport de domination
intellectuelle et politique que
l'Occident à l'époque c'était les
Français et les anglais puis après ça
les Américains ont pris le la suite qui
fait que on a cessé de prendre des
décisions à la place des auteurs de la
région pour leur bien donc il y a eu
effectivement les accords sapico il y a
eu la TR trahison de de que que Laurence
d'Arabie a subi quand on pr était une
grande nation arabe qui finalement ne
s'est pas faite il y a eu le fait que
même dans le PCT du Quincy quand
Roosevelt rencontre i Saoud il lui dit
promet que effectivement il y aura pas
de création de l'État d'Israël sans que
il soit consulté évidemment il il se
fera sans sans le
consulter il y a tout si vous voulez tu
veux cette cette espèce de prise de
décision continue qui fait que les
Occidentaux ont géré la région à leur
avantage bon il y a un exemple qui est
absolument prodigieux qui est celui du
11 septembre dans lequel on a 15
saoudiens sur 19 terroristes et par un
tour de passe-pe fantastique qui prouve
d'ailleurs l'influence à revers de
certains pays de la région sur les
décideurs George buouche décide que
l'axe du mal c'est l'Iran l'Irak et la
Corée du Nord trois pays dont ne venait
aucun des terroristes et donc on est
dans cette espèce de de méconnaissance
ou en tout cas de connaissance perfide
de la région euh et puis le fait que les
décideurs de la région eux-mêmes sont
totalement déconsidérés c'està-dire
aussi le nationalisme arabe est mort
Assad est quand même un effroyable
dictateur im Saoud est un espèce
d'allumé enfin im Saou la famille des la
dynastie des des rois d'Arabie Saoudite
est une espèce de comment dire de
directeur d'asile psychiatrique qui en
plus diffuse son modèle à l'étranger
donc on est dans une situation
fantastique parce que on va battre
contre daesh pour le défendre l'Arabie
Saoudite il y a un article du New York
Times récemment qui est très bien fait
j'ai malheureusement oublié le nom de
l'auteur c'est universitaire français il
dit l'Arabie Saoudite c'est un DA qui a
réussi voilà c'est la formule est assez
juste
Hervé quand quand on voit que on
commerce on a des partenariats des
contrats avec les directeurs de l'asile
psychiatrique l'Arabie Saoudite ou
comment les journalistes se comportent
par rapport à ce type
d'information comment il se
comporte
normalement doivent enquêter et faire le
travail c'est plus compliqué qu'il n'y
paraît en fait à travers cette question
tu es en train de me dire qu'est-ce que
vous foutez ouais sors-toi les doigs du
cul oui euh pour le
coup je pense
qu'on on se les sort pas si mal je sais
que c'est honteux de dire ça aux yeux et
aux oreilles de l'Internet de l'Internet
l'idée c'est que on vient de loin c'est
un sujet très complexe après tout la
qualité de l'info la qualité du
journalisme à quoi tout cela se
mesure-t-il je disais que la première
fois que je suis confronté à la violence
terroriste en ce qui me concerne c'est
la rue des rosiers et donc à l'époque il
y avait aussi un terrorisme national qui
était action directe la Corse le le
pays- basque beaucoup de choses sur
lesquelles auxquelles j'ai été confronté
à chaque fois il fallait comprendre ce
qui était en train de se passer
travailler se cultiver au sens plein du
terme et il fallait pas simplement dire
regarder tous ces morts et et parfois
même faire tout l'historique des morts
par un certain moment nous ne faisions
que ça mais plus loin de qui consistait
à expliquer d'où cela venait quelle
était la
situation qui est ce caché derrière un
texte de
revendication c'est un gros
investissement et à la télévision en
particulier un investissement je dirais
même plus globalement mais surtout à la
télé c'est un investissement auquel le
média n'était pas franchement enclin
c'està-dire de faire réellement une
enquête de fond longue avec toute la
toute l'implication que ça suppose en
terme de temps et de moyens et donc il a
fallu parce que ça c'est il y a 30 ans
40 ans jouer des coupes pour peu à peu
imposer la simple dimension de l'enquête
à la télé qui n'allait pas de soi CQ
colonnes à la une était une émission qui
était essentiellement du reportage pour
voir ce qui était en train de se passer
euh interviewit les grands acteurs du
moment mais la dimension d'une réelle
enquête n'était pas vraiment à l'ordre
du jour de CQ colonnes c'est pour ça
qu'on a vu les réseaux gladiux émerger
en Europe bien sûr je sais pas si c'est
pour ça mais en tout cas nous n'avons
pas été à la hauteur des grands défis de
l'histoire qui se déroulait à ce
moment-là c'est
clair parce que le le le je dirais le
contrepoison que peut représenter l'info
n'était pas au rendez-vous il était un
peu en cours d'élaboration il y a des
types qui se disaient [__] il faut
qu'on le fasse qui des journalistes des
responsables de redac ils ont sauté pas
forcément sont des gens qui ont pu faire
leur travail certains oui sont je dirais
morts au champ d'honneur
Eric le traitement de l'information sur
là moi j'ai été j'ai quand j'étais
militaire j'étaé formé à l'OT temp sur
les ce qu'on appelle les techniques de
information
operation en gros ça c'est le terme on
va dire politiquement correct en gros
manipulation de
l'information c'était à peu près en 2008
c'est qu'on nous apprenait comment sur
un théâtre d'opération il fallait
présenter l'information pour que les
autorités civiles militaires les
journalistes de choses gob gob les
choses et bref un certain nombre de
choses pas forcément acceptables le
deviennent en fait ce que ce que je vois
actuellement quand je regarde la télé
comme je veux dire en étant des deux
côtés c'est l'homme de la rue et ayant
sui cette formation je vois en fin de
compte que ces techniques mainant se
sont répandus partout et qu'on est
effectivement sur alors le le mot est
peut-être un peu fort mais une forme de
censure qui dit pas son nom dans une
forme de manipulation des des individus
et je pense qu'en ce moment avec les
derniers les derniers événements elle
est encore à l'œuvre on l'a vu sur des
sur des tas de questions notamment dans
la région du prochet Moyen-Orient bref
on est dans ilut faut quand même appeler
un chat à un chat on est sur des
techniques de manipulation pierre ore
Chalo la propagande de gu moi je
voudrais revenir sur le la mise en
accusation des journalistes moi je mise
en accusation attend je vais revenir
là-dessus parce que la formation de
l'information la formation de l'opinion
si tu veux ce n'est pas que les
journalistes bon moi là je suis beaucoup
plus sensible à l'espèce de silence
extraordinaire des des des politiques ou
des administrations sur le sujet parce
que on a donné des leçons de droit de
l'homme à tout le monde sauf à certains
pays clients j'en ai un en particulier
en tête mais qui fait que on a
absolument délivré des brevets de droits
de l'homme allant depuis l'Extrême
Orient jusqu'à l'extrême sud de
l'Amérique latine mais il y avait des
zones dans lesquels on ne disait jamais
un mot bon et ça ça contribue à la
formation de l'opinion ensuite il y a un
deuxième strate qui est celle de
l'administration c'est-à-dire comment
est-ce qu'on fait une note pour un
ministre comment on fait une note pour
un ministre mais on revient jamais en
arrière sur l'histoire du pays
c'est-à-dire on reprend la note
précédente on la met à jour et on lui
dit alors moi j'ai trouvé cette
argumentation très souvent sur les pays
du golf c'est en gros ces gens-là ils
nous aiment comme des fous d'ailleurs
regardez ils sont il nous achèteent des
armes il nous achèteent des tas de
choses et cetera et puis euh avec ce
sentiment de connaître la région
puisqu'on y allait souvent bon et quand
on va souvent dans un endroit mais qu'on
rencontre toujours les mêmes personnes
on fait de la soviétologie c'est-à-dire
on dit oui celui-là je l'ai vu la
dernière fois mais il était rentré
numéro 3 par la porte alors que là il
est rentré numéro 2 donc il est monté en
grade tu vois mais comprendre la société
comprendre ses motivations par exemple
on utilisait dans les télégrames
diplomatiques des concept que que tu as
dû voir c'est les francophiles et
francophobes comme si le monde était
divisé en deux camps sa où il y avait
les gens qui aimaient la France les gens
qui aimaient pas que les gens puissent
être nationalistes c'est-à-dire à
certain moment avoir des relations avec
la France d'une certaine nature et puis
changer de bord c'est pas ces concepts
là qui expliquent c'est de les
comprendre c'est le problème de la
culture c'est le problème de dire à à
ton par exemple jamais un ambassadeur ne
dira à son ministre d'affaires
étrangères vous savez votre opinion sur
la crise dans laquelle je suis tout le
monde s'en fout ici on va expliquer au
contraire au ministrees que sa prise de
position est absolument essentielle
parce que la France mon permanant du
Conseil de sécurité puissance nucléaire
en un seul mot tac tu tu as conditionné
le truc et cette formation de l'opinion
là cette formation de ces élites se
traduit dans la perception de l'opinion
donc les journalistes ils ont l'avantage
de faire du terrain mais tu as jamais vu
un homme politique sortir de cercle dans
lequel il va faire son invitation pour
aller voir à quoi ressemble le souc pour
aller voir comment se fait une
décapitation sur une place publique en
Arabie Saoudite c'est ça la réalité et
donc moi je dédoine les journalistes
parce que ceuxlà il faut ils réajustent
continuellement leur logiciel j'ai
d'autres milieux dans lesquels je suis
moins sensible les militaires ont
souvent d'ailleurs la la capacité à
pouvoir dire les choses simplement la
question c'est comme ils sont dans la
grande muette on les écoute pas bah ils
ont le devoir de réserve le problème
c'est faut quand même comprendre que et
je rejoins pierre sur la sur le mutisme
voir la céité de nos administrations
mais il faut comprendre ce que c'est que
l'administration française notamment
dans le domaine dans le domaine régalien
en gros pour un exécutif on a un certain
nombre de chef sous-chef autrement dit
on a un C nombre de gens qui ne
produisent rien les
médiocres éventuellement on va dire
disons de gens non productifs ces
gens-là dans la fonction publique ils
doivent progresser parce qu'ils sont a
certains seril et autres et il y a un
maître mot c'est quand on ne fait rien
on peut pas se tromper hm hm c'est vrai
ou donc on a une fossilisation à
différents niveaux euh de de de gens qui
au contraire devraient parler et les
militaires on leur reproche leur devoir
de réserve mais souvent ça ne veut pas
dire qu'il ne faut pas preuve un
d'initiative deune certaine liberté de
parole dès que ça n'engage pas la
défense le problème c'est qu'ils sont
très vite rappelés à l'ordre faut quand
même rappeler que depuis 1980 les
générau sont nommés par le pouvoir
politique non plus par les militaires ce
qui ce qui est une forme disons de de
contrôle qui dit pas son nom mais
effectivement cette fossilisation cette
stratification à l'extrême euh des
entités gouvernementales et en
particulier des services de
renseignement fait que bah on est dans
une inercie totale moi j'ai vu je
connais souvent des cas où à l'étranger
le renseignement se fait dans les
cocktails se fait pas dans la Mdina se
fait pas dans les sur le terrain se fait
pas au contact des gens ça c'était la
culture coloniale troupe de marine où on
est on vivait avec les populations et
finalement chaque militaire était un
capteur et qui renseignait mais le
problème du renseignement c'est que vous
pouvez collecter autant de formation que
l'on veut il faut qu'après les chefs ait
envie de l'écouter de le traiter d'y
croire il faut surtout pas que ça
vienne déranger la vision préétablie
donc il y a des fois des choses qu'on
met sur le tapis pour revenir dans dans
le sens de ce que tu dis moi j'ai vécu
un épisode absolument cocasse j'étais en
Iran avec Régis de Bray on va à Rome à
la ville sainte on rencontre des des
ayatollah avec qui on discute enfin bon
des types très intelligents avec tout
l'argumentaire qu'on va avir enfin les
Jésuites de le du chisme quoi et puis il
y a dans la la réunion un Français qui
vit en Iran depuis 79 que le type soit
converti au chisme pas j'en sais rien
toujours qu'il avait fait sa thèse à
l'époque sur la théologie de de roméie
mais le système universitaire français
disait mais attendez que ça nous
intéresse le théologie de roméie bon
donc ce type s'est fixé là-bas et puis
on donc il était le meilleur traducteur
que le traducteur officiel qui nous
avait donné on revient à la à Tan et on
été invité le soir chez l'ambassadeur
alors il nous dit bah est-ce que je peux
venir avec vous c'est difficile c'est
pas nous qui invitons on va pas te leur
dire on a vu de la lumière on est monté
avec un copain donc il vient pas et on
arrive dans un dîner dans lequel il y
avait le prototype du contact Contin
continu de tous les ambassadeurs qui
succèdent sur un poste c'est-à-dire le
francophone local qui est un pur produit
de nos lycées français de l'étranger et
qui connaît mieux la vie politique
française que toi et qui vient te parler
de la vie politique française alors que
le type intéressant c'était celui qui
était dehors c'était celui qui était
justement au contact de la sphère
décisionnelle iranienne mais celui-là je
pense que nos services avaient dû dire
ouh là là il faut se méfier de lui parce
que celui-là il vit là-bas depuis entend
donc il a dû être tamponné il a dû être
converti et tu vois le le truc et c'est
ça le paradoxe c'est que si un type est
propre sur lui qu'il est un produit des
systèmes français Jean Bassou il est
effectivement l'homme qu'il faut
contacter mais faire cet effort de se
dire non mais attant celui qu'on doit
comprendre c'est l'autre c'est c'est
l'ennemi c'est celui qui pense
exactement à l'opposé de nous celui-là
on fait pas l'effort c'est les
journalistes qui le font c'est pas les
politiques parfois ils le font je le dis
parce que voilà c'est vrai au péril de
leur vie moi je suis du service public
et Franch frement on a payé cher en
terme de liberté et en terme de vie
humaine et donc que je voudrais dire
c'est que il n'y a pas d'un côté la
pureté de l'info et de l'autre côté la
censure c'est plus compliqué que ça
parce que si on s'attaquait à la censure
et qu'on la lève et à Dieu ne plaise
comme dirait d'autres ça se fait quand
même dans notre quotidien j'ose
l'autocensure
attends je parle de la censure en tant
que
telle on pourrait donc avoir
si le truc était simplement duel avoir
une pureté de l'info et ce serait le
nirvana de la démocratie tous les jours
or c'est pas ça parce que l'info c'est
un Moulot et donc c'est pas simplement
une affaire de on m'interdit de dire la
vérité c'est que cette vérité je dois
travailler pour la trouver la construire
la l'élaborer et la transmettre c'est un
très grand travail et c'est quelque
chose dont on doit prendre conscience
comme étant un
élément fondateur de la démocratie et du
rôle des journalistes en
démocratie et donc cet investissement là
et cette prise de conscience encore une
fois oui j'ose le dire depuis 30 ans ou
40 ans va grandissant sur les antennes
grandissant oui y compris dans les
journaux télévisés il y a ici et là
énormément d'infos qui passent il y a
dans les magazines énormément
d'informations qui passent il y a plein
de boîtes de prod et des gens à
l'intérieur des chaînes et je dis aussi
du service public qui a pris conscience
quand même du rôle qui est le sien de
défendre ce journalisme offensif tant
dans les que pièce à conviction cache où
on voit bien qu'il y a quand même
quelque chose qui part à
l'assaut s'ffronte c'est tellement peu
c'est tellement peu c'est peu pourquoi
pourquoi je t'ai fait venir aujourd'hui
parce que tu as travaillé pour c pas
cache investigation non moi j'ai j'ai
fait pièce à conviction je respecte
totalement les amis de première ligne
qui font cash et et et des tas d'autres
émissions ou de reportages des journaux
on va parler du 20ur c'est-à-dire le ce
que tu connais bien qu'est-ce qui fait
la discrimination par rapport aux 5000
dépêche de la FP tous les jours qui fait
la le le journal et comment ça se fait
que vous vous copiez les uns les autres
c'est une c'est une grande question
parce que on ne se téléphone pas j'ai
essayé d'y réfléchir j'ai essayé de
faire un petit bouquin là-dessus pour
comprendre parce que je cherche du sens
à ce que j'ai pu faire dans dans dans
dans une petite vie professionnelle et
ça m'emmerde qu'on pose sans arrêt les
mêmes questions depuis 40 ans ou 50 ans
sur les journalistes c'est-à-dire ça
fait 40 ans que c'est-à-dire depuis 40
ans on dit qu'on est des pourris qu'on
est des vendus qu'on est ceci qu'on est
cela et ça ne progresse pas ça ne fait
pas avancer la chose alors qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire pour avancer ben il
faudrait comprendre ce qu'on est en
train de faire et comment ça marche h
par exemple la question que tu dis que
tu poses pardon h pourquoi est-ce que
vous dites tous la même chose d'abord je
soutiens l'idée que ça a été vrai mais
que ça allait beaucoup moins
qu'auparavant j'ai essayé d'analyser
tous les 10 ans ce qui était le
fonctionnement médiatique à une date qui
devait être en octobre je me souviens
plus j'ai j'ai choisi une date
arbitraire et j'ai vu que dans les
années 50 60 70 il y a une diversité
considérable et au fur et à mesure qu'on
va vers les années il y a une
uniformisation du discours
journalistique rien que ce petit
travail il est à mon avis à développer à
savoir ce qui s'est passé il faut que
les historiens s'en
emparent pour pour pour répondre à cette
question là qui est une question
politique pour moi de fond et
d'urgence parce que nous sommes face à
un point crucial y compris pour en
revenir à
DAEs dans ce que nous vivons
c'est une défiance
radicale de ceux pour lesquels on est en
train de parler là sur Youtube de tout
le web qui me conchie moi le journaliste
ainsi que tous mes
confrère je pense que cette situation
est politiquement épouvantable et qu'il
faut que nous retrouvions la confiance
des personnes à quel prix au prix de
l'intelligence de savoir ce que nous
faisons l'intelligence de ce que nous
faisons c'est déjà montrer comment on
fonctionne c'està-dire adopter une
démarche de transparence qui est un peu
celle de cache précisément c'est-à-dire
quand je cherche une info je vais
trouver quelqu'un et je lui pose des
questions il est d'accord pas d'accord
mais le journaliste a retrouvé droit de
citer dans l'image tu vois par exemple
les les jeunes mecs que ce soit au Petit
Journal ou au 20h ou ailleurs on revoit
les journalistes à l'antenne il fut tout
un temps où les journalistes cétaient
monsieur
voisof on on les avait perdu de vue à sa
colonnes on savait qui étaient les mecs
Roger Louis sur le terrain la France
entière le connaissait c'était un
reporter identifié je pense que le
gommage des journalistes dans à
l'antenne a été un des premiers facteurs
de de perte de confiance parce que
c'était plus un boulot c'était comme une
sorte de grande caméra de sécurité qui
se trimballait de par le monde avec une
voix non identi
et on te disait le grand message
interplanétaire ça a concouru très
certainement à encore une fois perdre
les gens deuxième point une attitude qui
n'était plus celle de l'enquêteur mais
celle de l'examinateur pour moi de
l'info examiner l'info c'est la
problématiser c'est commencer à rentrer
dans une manière de voir les choses qui
est plus de l'ordre du gouvernement des
gens que du questionnement
journalistique résumer trivialement
c'est passage de plat ces passages de
plat gare à la trivialité pourquoi gare
à la trivialité parce que la trivialité
parfois fait que tu caricatures un truc
qui mérite beaucoup mieux pour qu'on y
remédie un mec a un gros rume le mec se
pointe devant le le le tbib et le tbib
dis un gros rume en fait derrière le
type se peigne un cancer du poumon moi
ce qui m'intéresse c'est de tenter
d'avoir un diagnostic eff ce parce que
je pense encore une fois que
politiquement oui il se pose des
questions très graves très lourdes que
ce soit d'ailleurs pour le service
public comme pour tous les privés sur le
terrain de l'information et daesh de ce
point de vue là nous lance un défi
considérable qui est celui oui de la
qualité de l'information je peux te dire
que dans les rédactions tout le monde en
est conscient et que ça si tu veux ça ça
ça exige ça veut il y a pas une bande de
typ qui sont là prêt pour Dieu sait quel
petit salaire ou grand salaire à à
passer le plat fourbi par mon ami le
militaire ou celui de l'ignorance de ce
qui se passe non parce que toutes ces
générations à commencé par les jeunes
qui eux aussi sont sur le numérique
Internet et autres comment dire qui
travaillent à la télé savent que il faut
aller au-delà quoi il faut se remuer et
ils sont exigeants
Éric Filiol il y a jamais de fumé sans
feu disons que moi je su je rejoins en
grande partie ce que a dit il y a des
journalistes qui de grande qualité le
problème c'est qu'il faut faut avoir une
vision beaucoup plus large les
journalistes n plus n'évoluent plus dans
un monde seul il faut il a parlé
d'agence de de production il y a aussi
des agences de com et le principe de
l'infoope c'est d'allumer des feux des
contrefeux c'est-à-dire en gros au
moment où une information pertinente
sort elle est on s'arrange pour qu'elle
soit noyée moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est
pas souvent l'information c'est la
corrélation d'un certain nom
d'information prés au même moment donc
le but effectivement moi je suis
convaincu je il y a des journalistes
comme ise lu en moi que j'admire
énormément c'est amusant de voir comment
elle est traitée elle est traitée
notamment par un certain nombre de
communicants que je distingue des des
journalistes en fait ce système de feu
et de contrefeu permet effectivement bah
de noyer le poisson et d'atténuer un
certain nombre de de très Bones de très
bons articles de très bonnes réflexions
mais le problème c'est qu'effectivement
euh les journalistes ne sont pas seuls
ils sont maintenant dans un contexte
économique qui est extrêmement contraint
et le pouvoir de l'argent les moyensin
c'est aussi aller sur le terrain et tout
ça coûte cher maintenant
euh voilà c'est il je pensais un livre
de Flor vassur je crois que c'est
l'association de malfaiteur le le
dernier chapitre en bande organisée en
bande organisée voilà et je crois que
bon c'est souscouverneun roman c'est
pour moi une très bonne enquête qui dit
pas son nom le dernier chapitre illustre
parfaitement ce qui est en train de se
passer au niveau de du journalisme
versus la communication et ce système de
feu et de contrefeu elle l'explique
parfaitement c'est ça il y a des
journalistes qui qui font très bien leur
travail qui sont particulièrement
gênants et je reviens à ellise Lucet moi
encore une fois une personne que
j'admire particulièrement on voit très
bien comment elle est mal mené et par le
pouvoir politique par une certaine
partie de ses confrères j'ai discuté
avec certains de ses collègues dit c'est
pas facile tous les jours pour elle mais
bon voilà il y a encore des gens
courageux le problème c'est que le
courage se paye souvent cache et donc de
moins en moins sont tentés de suivre
cette voix oua Denis Robert a payé très
cher Pierre connais ça je vous écoute
jeoute moi si tu veux je suis toujours
un peu à la marche le procès fait aux
journalistes c'est le procès le plus
aisé adresser parce que tout le monde
accède aux médias et tout le monde se
dit oui mais en fait il raconte C il
raconte ça moi je ferai plusieurs
remarques d'abord qu'un événement puisse
être une une double lecture c'est
quelque chose auquel nous ne sommes pas
habitués je te prends un exemple quand
le les les soviétique se retire
d'Afghanistan en Occident tout le monde
dit là le communisme a reculé et cetera
vous voyez finalement notre politique a
été payante et cetera le même moment tu
un communiqué de Ben Laden disant voyez
une armée de militants de de arabe
musulman est capable de de gagner sur la
plus traditionnelle la plus
conventionnelle des armées la plus
puissante des armées conventionnelles de
l'époque mais qui va lire le communiqué
de Ben Laden à l'époque personne parce
que encore une fois c'est la focale
intellectuelle sur laquelle on eston or
Dieu sait que l'homme qui était promis
au plus B avenir c'était plutôt Ben
Laden que le ministre que le président
de l'époque je sais pas si c'était le
père bouche ou pas bon et donc ça cette
espèce de dualité de la de la réalité
c'est celui qu'on est en train de vivre
sur daesch on est en train de construire
sur DA un discours de la diabolisation
du mal absolu du fait qu'il faut
extirper cette cette entité malfaisante
et cetera encore une fois pour défendre
l'Arabie saudite donc tu vois bien
comment le regard pervertit la chose moi
il y a une chose aussi que la télévision
nous a fait naître et qui me paraît
beaucoup plus extraordinaire c'est le
présentateur de de journal c'est-à-dire
celui qui n'est pas le journaliste mais
celui qui présente les les reportages
fait par les autres et celui-là devient
un penseur de la société contemporaine
ça celui qui fait plus de terrain et
celui qui devient le penseur de
l'information je veux pas te citer des
exemples enfin ça m'a toujours beaucoup
choé OK et la dernière chose c'est
qu'encore une fois il y a pas que les
journalistes qui font de l'information
il y a tous les autres alors il y a
évidemment les boîtes de com qui
interviennent de plus en plus dans la
gestion de tu sais l'invention
concomitante de la publicité de la
propagande c'est quand même un épisode
historique qui est intéressante parce
que la publicité c'est rien plus que de
la propagande commerciale et la
propagande ça n'est rien de plus que de
la publicité politique c'est quand même
ça la méthodologie mêm qui vontvenir et
tu as aujourd'hui des gens comme des
intellectuels médiatiques qui vont faire
l'opinion parce que leur capacité à agir
sur l'opinion en faisant un grand
Antartique pour se placer au niveau des
principes pour dire queon devrait jamais
laisser faire il faut absolument
exterminer ses ses vermines et cetera
euh comme BHV B BHL pardon je confonds
c'est mais on peut retrouve la même
chose aussi on trouve tout chez BHL de
toute façon et donc on a effectivement
des gens qui sont capables d'agir sur le
politique pour prendre une décision qui
ne fait jamais l'objet d' d'un débat qui
fait jamais l'objet d'un débat
parlementaire et donc ces gens-là aussi
sont des gens qu'il faut
fondamentalement dénoncer et et ça que
je sa j'ai même vu un type qui un jour
avec expliqué à propos de l'Afghanistan
que il fallait faire un grand plan
Marshal pour l'Afghanistan c'està
fallait développer l'industrie en
Afghanistan le type il avait jamais mis
les pieds en Afghanistan quand on
connaît l'Afghanistan c'est la dernière
idée qui vient mais il était à Paris il
écrivait dans un grand quotidien du
matin et donc voilà ce type était là en
train de dire peut-être qu'il aurait
débloqué du fric en plus donc faites
attention l'opinion publique n'est pas
faite que par les journalistes elle est
faite par un certain nombre d'acteurs
dans lesquels tu vas avoir l'historien
qui va expliquer que depuis longtemps la
France est le pays des droits de l'homme
alors que la des constitutions
américaines datent de 776 tu vas avoir
le géographe qui va expliquer que la
France est au centre des terres habité
et que donc par la même c'est le pays de
l'harmonie tu vas avoir les juristes qui
vont expliquer que le droit
international les droits de l'homme en
48 ont été écrits par un français René
Cassin alors qu'on était la deuxième
puissance coloniale de la planète donc
tu vois c'est tout ça c'est important et
ça il faut le prendre en compte Hervé
est-ce que tu t'es posé la la la
question sur pourquoi les gens avaient
ciblé en priorité les journalistes par
rapport à ce cette déliquessence
sociétale
bah parce qu'ils le font encore une fois
depuis très longtemps non parce que vous
êtes les plus proches d'eux et que vous
êtes le 4e pouvoir oui c'est ça oui bien
sûr 4è pouvoir ça voilà déjà on est dans
dans moi je ne sais pas si le 4e le 5e
on
est on incarne une une capacité
stupéfiante dans une société qui
consiste à être préposé au discours de
vérité
c'est nous qui devons dire la vérité
hein et
donc historiquement dans l'Antiquité ça
s'est parfois passé assez mal pour les
mecs qui disaient la vérité que ce soit
des philosophes ou des coureurs de
marathon mais au-delà de la
plaisanterie le le le le la fonction de
de dire la vérité est une fonction de
récit de narration qui n unee valeur
relative par rapport à l'engagement et
l'implication personnelle des gens par
exemple on a souvent dit que c'était les
journalistes qui faisait le bulletin de
vote mais heureusement que ça ne se
passe pas comme ça sinon les Français et
le monde entier serait une population de
vous h regardant la télé est-ce que
est-ce que je peux t'arrêter là oui tu
sais qu'on a on a mis en lumière quand
même
le le fait que plus un homme politique
est représenté à la télé plus sa côte de
popularité augmente quand même est-ce
que tu as entendu est-ce que tu as
entendu est-ce que tu est-ce que tu as
entendu les dernières déclarations de de
notre ami vandé1 comment il
s'appelle Philippe dev Villier est-ce
que tu as suivi ce qu' raconé par
rapport au fait qu'il avait un un de ses
amis qui sponsorisait sa campagne qui
lui a dit bon ben il faut acheter du TF1
comme ça on passera plus sur TF1 qu'on
sera plus dans les institutes son
qu'est-ce que tu en penses oui je pense
que c'est une c'est une grosseierrté
majeure il y a eu un président de la
République qui adorait passer à la télé
qui a d'ailleurs en terme de Come innové
euh des repas avec les éboueurs des des
brouillés petit matin qui est qui est
passé très fortement à la télé et qui
pour le coup l'avait mise ici et là en
coupe règlé il n'a pas été réélu ce
garçon ça n'est pas aussi
simple la propagande le fonctionnement
de la propagande dans son son son
comment dire son effic cité est
heureusement chose un peu plus complexe
que diffusion d'un message et et
réflexe animal de la
personne je voudrais juste dire une
chose il y a un truc qui est quand même
assez rigolo pour moi c'est que les
journalistes sont mis en accusation et
c'est bien d'ailleurs parce que comme le
disait l'homme exdgse ERC filol je sais
mais je on s'amuse
c'est
que du coup tu m'as fait perdre ma
pensée c'est que le
journalisme est absolument
triomphant en ce sens aujourd'hui non
non j'ai pas peuras peur de rien j'ai
pas peur tu vas voir comment
tu tu vtir en et pourquoi parce que tout
le monde aujourd'hui a capacité à
produire sa vérité et ça je trouve non
c'est pas un problème c'est une grande
bonne nouv une émergence de gourou
phénoménal sur Internet possible tu as
raison mais c'est ça aussi le
fourmillement de la démocratie et il
faut savoir l'accepter quand même c'est
pas à moi de te le dire donc les formes
utilisées le le la
breveté pardon mais sont des techniques
qui ont été mises en place dans un art
de faire respectable qui est un vrai
métier qui s'appelle le journalisme et
je prétends
qu'aujourd'hui le journalisme est
effectivement triomphant et j'ose
espérer que il le sera il sera plus
satisfaisant pour la démocratie
aujourd'hui qu'il ne le fut mais c'est
cette capacité d'information et encore
une fois comment dire ordonné comme tu
sais par exemple je me souviens qu'un
sociologue avait travaillé sur la
conversation et de voir à quel point le
journalisme avait changé les modalité de
la conversation les avait rendu plus
brèves avait obligé les gens à aller
plus vite à l'essentiel parce que voilà
il y a il y a toute cette force là d'un
art de Fire permanent qu'on voit à la
télévision je crois moi davantage à une
formation à une implication sur la vie
des gens de cet ordre-là que la simple
fabrication d'une opinion et d'un
bulletin de vote c'est beaucoup plus
insidieux beaucoup plus profond c'est
plus complexe et c'est pour ça que ça
vaut le coup qu'on s'y penche davantage
en terme d'intelligence de ce qui se
passe que en terme de grande BAFF dans
la gueule que je vais me prendre il y a
pas de souci
là-dessus au
moins parce que j'ai toujours été
candidat à ça moi je viens c'est pour
parler avec les personnes et donc pour
essayer d'avoir cet échange je suis pas
en train de plaider une sorte de pseudo
virginité on est tous d'enfer et c'est
génial non c'est très compliqué mais ce
ce que je souhaite c'est simplement dans
le respect que moi je dois aux gens que
eux en retour respectent ma complexité
parce que j'en ai une et que ça n'est
pas si simple Éric Filiol on a vu
émerger un pouvoir un pouvoir à cœur on
a été obligé de sortir du bois qu'est-ce
que qu'est-ce que tu peux nous en dire
bon d'abord il a déjà il existe depuis
très longtemps je faut quand même
expliquer qu'Internet est né avec les à
cœur in d'abord on pense souvent que les
haurs sont des gens qui attaquent faut
quand même pas oublier que ce sont des
gens qui ont créé les premiers
protocoles même le gouvernement
américain même sil veut pas le
reconnaître a quand même
sous-traité le une bonne partie de la
création d'Internet à ce qu'on appel
autre fois des universitaires mais les
universitaires d'autre fois étaient plus
proche des hackurs que les
universitaires d'aujourd'hui bref euh je
reviens quand même à ce que disait HERV
le problème c'est que on est on a perdu
la culture de la prise de risque et le
problème c'est que dans le journalistme
qui fait son travail
euh c'est un peu comme les bon les
mauvais chasseurs hein c'est pour
reprendre le problème c'est qu'on
confond souvent le message et le
messager or en France prend prendre du
risque et je parlais des des
fonctionnaires c'est c'est devenu
totalement étranger notre culture donc
dès qu'il y en a un qui essaie de faire
les choses correctement de de faire les
choses et donc de prendre des risques il
se fait allumer méchamment mais les
hackurs quelque part ont un peu cette
position quand il ils arrivent ils
disent ah bah ça y est moi j'ai j'ai je
vais vous montrer que tel industriel qui
est sponsorisé par l'État il a fait un
truc qui tient pas la route parce que on
est rentré dedans par différentes
manières et en gros c'est du travail
d'amateur il est clair que le message a
du mal à passer et qu'il est plutôt vu
comme il est catalogué pirate parce que
ça arrange les gens alors qu'en réité
c'est un lanceur d'alerte technologique
et qu'il a il il a fait œuvre utile donc
dans le domaine spécifique parce que
l'essentiel des hackurs à ce en ce
moment travaille plutôt dans le domaine
technique même si on voit émerger des
hackeurs plus humains qui qui vont
hacker essayer de comprendre par ex
comment se font les lois ou autres donc
c'est cette démarche intellectuelle un
peu intéressante mais ils sont pas bien
vu eu en particulier en France alors
c'est c'est assez paradoxal parce qu'en
France on a une des meilleures
communautés à cœur au monde et on on
sait on l' met non seulement la méprise
on se coupe d'elle complètement mais ils
sont vu effectivement chaque fois que
comme des du poil à gratter et et voir
de de dangereux activistes terroristes
qui une version simpliste des choses
hein je crois que euh il y a un aspect
que les médias dans lesquel les médias
on ont largement pesé parce que leur
dynamique économique imposait le
un certain nombre de de choix bon grosso
modo si on regarde le bouquin monde
rebelle qui est la seule référence
globale de l'ensemble des crises
insurrection euh guerre et cetera à la
surface de la planète grosso modo il y
en a 400 à 450 hein ça dépend des années
mais comment se fait le choix puisque
justement tu posais la question au
départ des dépêche de la FP la FP est un
formidable capteur d'information bien
supérieur à ce que'est notre réseau
diplomatique parce que encore une fois
c'est un travail de journaliste les gens
ils hésitent pas à aller voir celui qui
pense mal alors qu'un ambassadeur se
fait sanctionner c'est justement il va
voir le type qui pense mal bon et donc
ça c'est très important à comprendre bon
et donc comment se fait ce choix
question que tu posais au départ après
tu as une contrainte diplomatique
c'est-à-dire tu as à la fois la
dynamique des acteurs et puis tu as la
dynamique du du système médiatique les
acteurs bah il faut d'abord qu'ils aent
un certain nombre de caractéristiques
pour se faire connaître il faut qu'ils
correspondent à des critères médiatiques
il faut qu'ils a un leader charismatique
genre le DAL Lama par exemple 13e Dieu
vivant sur terre tu sais dont on fait
citoyen d'honneur de la ville de Paris
capitale ce qui a quand même une
performance il faut effectivement des
combattants qui se reconnaissent donc si
tu as des bons avec des trucs doré
orange saffran c'est quand même mieux
que si tuas des combattants palestiniens
ont tenu camoufler enfit tu vois il y a
un certain nombre de critères ça c'est
TR deuxième chose à ce momentlà tu
entres dans la médiatisation du conflit
il faut des image pas d'image pas de
crise donc ça il faut s'en rendre compte
comment veux-tu faire un journal dans
une chaîne d'info en continue pour
parler d'une crise qui va se passer
quelque part dans le nord du Mexique
mais où tu as rien bon troisème chose il
y a un timing de la des médias
c'est-à-dire tu sais très bien dans le
journal télévisé tu peux parler de deux
crises internationales pas plus tu vas
pas traiter 25 crises le le message se
dilu puis dernière chose il y a le
timing médiatique du reste du monde tu
annonsces jamais une crise pendant les
Jeux olympiques ou la Coupe du monde de
football c'est pas la peine les médias
sont saturés avec ça et donc tous ces
critèresl sont des filtres qui sont pas
volontaires qui sont des des filtres
mécaniques et qui font que effectivement
alors prenons le cas de l'Arabie
Saoudite que j'adore par-dessus tout un
journaliste qui va en Arabie Saoudite
d'abord effectivement il faut qu'il
accepte d' qu'on l'accepte dans les
sphères décisionnelles c'est pas
seulement voir les frasques des princes
saoudiens c'est voir comment
fonctionnent les ouema tu sais ceux qui
disent la terre est plate elle tourne
pas sur elle-même d'ailleurs la preuve
c'est que si un avion partait de Riad et
que la Terre tournait sur allemag il
pourrait jamais arriver à Pékin je te
cite im base qui était le grand tous les
mains bon c'est ces gens-là qu'il faut
rencontrer parce que c'est c'est ceux-là
qui sont la la société saoudienne
profonde ensuite tu as un universitaire
si le mec s'amuse à raconter ce que
c'est vraiment l'Arabie Saoudite mais il
perd son terrain peut plus et si tu as
un homme politique qui s'amuse à
critiquer l'Arabie Saoudite je ne te
laisse je te laisse supposer comment il
va être appelé à l'ordre par ses petits
camarades parce que premier client
français en matière d'armement depuis 20
ans moyen de lycée de très loin et en
plus on sait que c'est un pays qui
achète des armes pour pas les utiliser
c'est un pays qui a jamais fait la
guerre à Israël alors que la frontière
est à une quarantaine de kilomètres donc
ça va pourquoi va--on se poser des
problèmes puisqu'on sait que ils
achètent pas des armes ils achètent des
anxiolitiques ils achètent des garanties
de sécurité bon donc tu vois c'est
problématique il faut les vivre de
l'intérieur des types ils veulent
t'acheter des frégattes ils en en planté
une sur des rochers la fois ils ont
voulu les présenter au prince au prince
ministre de la Défense le mec il a dit
non refaites-les moi passer le type il
avait pas le temps de virer craque il
s'est planté et on a fait un magnifique
contrat qui s'appelle le contrat mouette
justement pour réparer les frégates que
le type avit planté et donc on est dans
cette logique là c'est-à-dire jusqu'à ce
que vraiment le débat saoudien
apparaisse et encore une fois par des
mécanismes qui sont un mélange de
médiatisation un mélange d'alerte
militaire un mélange d'alerte de crise
et cetera les dossiers n'apparaissent
pas et donc encore une fois il faut le
prendre dans sa dans sa totalité c'est
quand même extraordinaire qu'on arrive à
leur vendre des laboratoires P4 quand
même non alors ça c'est magnifique ça
c'est prodigieux parce que encore une
fois il faut être dans l'Arabie Saoudite
le celui qui est le dernier qui a vu un
Saoudien travailler si tu veux il est
pas là un laboratoire P4 pour nos
auditeurs tu expliques un peu alors un
laboratoire P4 c'est un laboratoire
extrêmement sensible qui permet de soit
de travailler sur des souches
biologiques extrêmement dangereuses donc
il y a des conditions d'isolement de
pratique et cetera deil trage et cetera
mais qui évidemment peuvent servir à
mettre en place des armes de destruction
massiv qui peuvent être des armes
bactériologiques biologiques et cetera
et donc ce sont des critères extrêmement
stricts si tu veux de fonctionnement
d'un laboratoire de cette nature c'est
toute la difficulté du débat sur les
armes bactériologiques parce que les
armes bactériologiques le meilleur
endroit pour faire une armes
bactériologique c'est un hôpital donc
évidemment comment on va contrôler tous
les hôpitaux de la planète en disant
attention là il y a un laboratoire qui
travaille sur la souche de la variole la
plus dangereuse le le meilleur exemple
c'est le c'est la la crise de l'antrax
après l'an septembre tout le monde l'a
oublié la crise de l'entrax parce que tu
te souviens de cette crise c'est-à-dire
les mecs ont reçu des des enveloppes
dans lesquelles il y avait des petits la
petite poudre blanche et cetera bon
alors juste un détail par rapport au
souches d'antrax je connais très bien
Bob Cohen qui est un ami qui a fait le
film anthrax War ou marchand d'antthrax
essaie de revenir un petit peu sur la
souche d'antthrax qui a été envoyé un
petit peu aux États-Unis c'était une
souche comment militarisée alors d'abord
il faut bien se rendre compte que on
était dans les effets du 11 septembre
c'estàdire que la télévision les médias
américains est complètement focalisé sur
les victimes trucs pourquoi nous aiment
pas et Cera et cetera sur ce se diffuse
par la poste un certain nombre
d'enveloppes contenant des B des ports
d'entrax militarisé parce que ces ports
d'entrax on s'est rendu compte que le
travail la militarisation de la por
d'entrax consiste à essayer de la rendre
la plus fine possible de façon à ce
qu'elle pénètre le plus profondément
possible dans l'organisme ce qui prouve
qu'il y a des gens quand même pour qui
l'éthique morale de la alors on peut
t'expliquer que c'est pour se prémunir
contre ce genre de risque c'est ça aussi
la dualité du comment dire de l'esprit
humain hein si on fait du mal c'est pour
le grand plus grand bien de l'humanité
les sous je ven les sous je venaent dans
laboratoire militaire et donc on a su
qu'il sortait d'un laboratoire militaire
ce qui en même temps prouvait qu'en
dépit de la convention chimique les
Américains continuent à entretenir des
laboratoires de fabrication d'armes
bactériologiques qu'ils expliquaient par
le fait que il fallait se prémunir
contre ces maladies donc il fallait
continuer à travailler et donc une des
raisons qui fait que par exemple les
conventions sur les armes
bactériologiques ne marchent pas c'est
que à la suite des États-Unis tout le
monde explique qu'on on doit protéger un
secret industriel c'est-à-dire qu'on
glisse du sécuritaire particulièrement
dangereux dont on va accuser l'autre de
le pratiquer pour te dire mais moi je
suis obligé de m'en prémunir donc je
fais la même chose alors on met pas ça
sur des supports militaires mais en tout
état de cause la crise de l'antthrax est
largement disparu de la scène médiatique
elle est passée sous les radars parce
que toute la problématique des
néoconservateurs était aujourd'hui il
faut se venger n on nous a déclaré la
guerre il faut faire la guerre et donc
si à ce moment-là c'est silence dans les
Rangs tu vois le truc et donc cette
articulation entre l'actualité brûlante
le rôle des médias le travail de fond et
le les vérités historiques je te
rappelle que le plus gros le premier
correspondant de guerre c'est Hérodote
qui part avec Alexandre sur pendant les
guerres de conquête d'Alexandre qui va
présenter Alexandre comme le
représentant de la démocratie grecque
alors qu'il a soumis toutes les cités
greces grec et qui va présenter l'empire
perse comme la dictature alors qu'en
fait la composante qu on regarde la
décomposition de l'armée pers c'était
une armée respectueuse de toutes les
minorité de l'empire de l'époque mais
comme c'est Hérodote qui écrit
l'histoire c'est fini les rôles sont
posés on a la démocratie grecque contre
la dictature àépoque il a un mec qui va
le le critiquer fortement qui s'appelle
tucidide ouais c'est vrai qui lui a fait
des guerres et autres qui veut pas que
ça recommence donc vous voyez ça date de
longtemps et qui dit lui vérifie pas ses
infos moi je vais les vérifier et doncit
travodote lui fait un premier travail
fondateur qui dit faut aller all sur
place pour savoir ce qui se passe et il
fait tout le tour de la Méditerranée il
écrit un gros machin qui s'appelle
l'enquête que j'invite à lire parce que
ça se lit comme un roman policier par
exemple tu es en Égypte tu viens d'avoir
un mort dans ta famille et tu reçois la
visite des mecs pour embaumer ton parent
et tu as tout le discours de est-ce
qu'on embaumme la tête et tout et
combien ça va me coûter et tout
autrement dit quand tu vas au louv voir
les momis que tu as lu ça tu le vois
déjà autrement et tu s dis lui après il
dit ok oui il faut aller sur le terrain
mais il faut vérifier recouper et donc
il il a introduit la notion des sources
et de la multiplicité des sources oui
oui oui euh je vais
quand je t'entends je pense au charnier
de Timmy soara donc ça me ah ben le
charnier de Timy Shara mais tu as
parfaitement raison je l'ai vécu en
direct ah ouais avec guillume dur non
non Guillaume Durand était sur une autre
chaîne ou
moiétais tant mieux pour moi déjà sur le
service public ouis bonjour et donc on
se l' pris comme ça et qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé pardon mais il y avait déjà
des une dépêche des dépêches réécrites à
Paris parce qu'on a fait l'histoire de
Timy choara on a essayé de comprendre
d'où
venait oui bien sûr mais c'est Paris qui
avait fait confiance à une agence
youoslave à l'époque qui s'appelle Tam
et qui avait écrit en fonction de ce que
nos amis à l'époque du KGB et autres
avaient bien fumé
et le truc a fonctionné mais peu de
temps car la vérité d'une escroquerie ne
dure que le temps de la vérité de cet
escroquri et on doit aussi à la fois aux
historiens et à tous les confrères
journalistes d'avoir fait le travail
d'autocritique les gens de la FP ont
écrit là-dessus et pour faire en sorte
que bah ça redémarre pas mais peut-être
que demain il y aura un autre timich
choira c'est possible mais après le
contrepoison doit venir c'est ça la
démocratie oui pi moi je vudrais
insister sur un aspect qui est quand
même le rôle du spectateur c'est-à-dire
qu'il a lui-même un background culturel
absolument il est évidemment de le pays
de l'harmonie universelle il devrait
parce que pour l'instant on forme plus
des consommateurs que des citoyens à
l'école tu peux pas t'empêcher de penser
que de toute façon on a tous un
background culturel et que ce background
culturel est celui qui va recevoir le
message bon si tu veux le cette la façon
dont euh on va formater l'information
parce qu'il faut aussi que le le
spectateur la comprenne est un travail
essentiel et donc le background culturel
Moen a des exemples qui me frappent
toujours c'est la production
hollywoodienne puisque le western est
quand même un style cinématographique
dans lequel c'est le génocideur le
cowboy qui qui est le héros et c'est la
les Indiens les Barbar qu'il faut
massacrer bon et on a tous adhéré à ce
discours ça veut dire qu'avec une
certaine forme tu as aussi des des
mécanismes de production du filtre
intellectuel des individus qui est
extrêmement important je prends un
exemple récent court courant hein court
non un exemple très simple c'est
American sniper ouais ouais American
sniper c'est un massacre c'est on fait
un héros d'un type qui tire à 1 km et
dem sur ses victimes qui est quand même
pas vraiment le combattant du front et
en plus on te le présente comme le type
qui revient trois quatre fois sur le
front et cetera puis on sent bien qu'il
s'emmerde chez lui quoi bon la partie la
plus intéressante c'est quand même quand
il est assassiné par un J qui a été
traumatisé par la guerre mais ça ça
n'est pas traité par clintstwood c'est
pas intéressant en même temps tu as sur
internet un film fait par un sniper
iraakien qui s'appelle Juba et donc qui
montre les prises de vue qu'il a fait
quand il tue des soldats américains et
tu te dis mais lequel des deux est un
film de propagande les deux ou il y en a
un qui ne l''est pas ou dans ce cas-là
il faut me dire pourquoi ou alors il
faut considérer que les deux ont le même
mécanisme de propagande et c'est ça qui
forme l'opinion donc le journaliste qui
va revenir en en disant en Irak on fait
un sale boulot on va lui dire mais
attendez monsieur nous sommes l'État de
la nous sommes la démocratie nous sommes
le droit Éric Filiol le background
culturel de du
spectateur bah il est important mais moi
je crains que alimenté par la la la
seule culture américaine il disparaisse
enfin on a un recul quand même de la
culture générale de ce pour l'instant on
juge à la lumière du de la génération
actuelle qui est encore qui a été formé
par un système éducatif qui était quand
même bon mais quand je dis que notre
système éducatif forma en plus des
consommateurs plutôt que des citoyens ça
veut dire que d'ici 10 ans on on aura
des populations totalement incultes dans
bien des domaines euh le rouleau
compresseur américain avec les séries
qui qui pollue l'esprit de nos jeunes
quand on supprime les épreuves de
culture générale l'entrée de grandes
écoles pour ne pas pour ne pas les citer
ça ça concourt pas à à à à maintenir un
niveau un niveau disons de de
préoccupation de du téléspectateur ou du
lecteur à un niveau suffisant euh donc
en gros si on faisz-vous général de GO
disait desvau les veau sont juste
connectés maintenant avec internet quand
on voit avec quelle frénésie les gens se
précipitent pour all acheter un Apple ou
autes qui payent une fortune voilà je
veux dire on a on a des veau connectés
juste un mot sur ce que tu viens de dire
moi j'étais aux États-Unis au mois
d'août et tu sais aux États-Unis tu as
des drapeaux américains partout sur les
bagnoles sur les barbecue sur les toit
des maisons et cetera et donc je me suis
dit mais pour comment peut-on être si
fier d'appartenir à une nation qui a été
esclavagiste génocidaire à l'égard des
Indiens ségrégationniste jusqu'aux
années 60 et encore raciste aujourd'hui
comme le montre un certain nombre de
prise de vue donc à la fin j'ai posé la
question parce que je dans une librairie
je voulais voir comment étaient fait les
manuels d'enseignement de l'histoire le
type m'a dit non il y a pas de manuel
d'enseignement de l'histoire vous avez
une série de biographies de héros
américains alors une année on fait
l'histoire de l'État à laquelle on dans
lequel on est la laabama la ya ce que tu
veux ensuite on fait une année
d'histoire des États-Unis pu fin on fait
une histoire année d'histoire du monde
et cette espèce de décérébration est
extraordinaire à vivre parce
qu'effectivement les types qui entrent
dans ce ce monde ont l'impression d'Er
comme les types qui vont à daesh ils
sont dans la société parfaite et alors
j'ai posé la question à un type il me
dit mais nous la passée ne nous
intéresse pas c'est l'avenir qui nous
intéresse
ouis ouais j'étais les bras Ballan je
savais pas quoi dire alors je vais vous
poser une question à tous les trois
concernant le ce qu'on est en train de
vivre en ce moment l'état d'urgence
l'état d'urgence
Hervé qu'est-ce que tu en penses l'état
d'urgence si ça se prolonge un peu trop
s'il y a un un transfert de la politique
sécuritaire américaine sur l'Europe et
la France en particulier c'està-dire un
patriotaac bien serré un état d'urgence
qui devient commun le NDAA tu tu me
diras si tu connais le NDAA National
Defense authorization
Act si on commence à avoir des des camps
d'internement ou de rétention comme aux
États-Unis le HR je pourrais te le
retrouver qu'est-ce que tu en penses je
pense que le warning s'est déjà allumé
au moment de la loi sur le renseignement
et que on a commencé très fortement à
s'agiter
euh c'està-dire à faire marcher notre
petite curiosité la mise en question la
mise en débat et que quelque part ça
quand même étit assez opératoire sur une
ou deux choses il y a eu des reculs qui
font que par exemple l'investigation
journalistique est encore possible alors
qu'on aurait voulu la limiter je parle
surtout du secret industriel et de la
manière dont on voulait l'utiliser pour
comment dire stopper toute curiosité
qualifiée de
malsène donc ce que je veux dire c'est
que évidemment état d'urgence il y a
urgence à rester plus que vigilant et en
question permanente en en en en en
travail de de comment dire
d'interrogation au plus haut point dans
toutes les éditions et par exemple je
sais que
sur le numérique chez nous à France TV
info on a déjà essayé de de voir tout ce
qui sortait tout tout ce qui était
abusif et donc on récolte tout ça on
fait ce travail
donc j'aime pas me prendre pour un
soldat genre les sentinelles de la
démocratie tout ça c'est vraiment du
c'est c'est c'est du verbiage voilà tu
fais
un un signe assez explicite mais toi on
ne voit pas je suis assez d'accord
là-dessus en revanche c'est de notre
fonction de notre rôle que de le faire
ça ça fait aussi partie du défi lancé
par la situation par la question
terroriste comment une démocratie
répondt-elle à à l'action terroriste et
comment l'information se définit-elle
par rapport à ça sur le chapitre crucial
des
libertés je suis descendu en PL
parce que on m'a demandé ça le lendemain
matin du Bataclan et de ce qui s'était
passé à Saint-Denis et j'ai commencer à
parler effectivement de cette affaire de
restriction de liberté parce
qu'immédiatement et on n'est pas né de
la dernière pluie on sait qu'il y aura
ça et donc on sait que à tout moment il
faut continuer à mettre en question et
faire en sorte que des pentes comme ça
qui pourraient s'offrir à tous les
pouvoirs qui soi de droite de gauche et
et j'espère pas d'autres euh feront que
on ira pas au bain quoi h Filiol Etat d'
urgence moi je pense que c'est c'est
c'est une stupidité d'abord c'est mé
cononnaître
euh comment ces gens-l fonctionne c'est
que j'ai eu l'occasion de traviller sur
certaines affaires on voit qu'ils savent
de mieux en mieux passer sous le radar
donc c'est pas une loi extrêmement
libertiile qui va permettre de détecter
les informations je rappelle quand même
que les renseignements les plus
pertinents nous été fournis par le Maroc
euh membre du Conseil de sécurité l'ONU
avec la bombe atomique on est quand même
à la ramasse en terme de renseignement
moi je pense que si il y a une urgence
ça c'est clair personne peut le nier
mais je préférais une réaction de type
chkchill qui disait bah les gars on va
tous se retrousser et je vous promet du
sang et des larmes plutôt qu'une vision
plutôt de type Eric concker en RDA parce
que ce qu'on est en train de mettre en
place qu'on le veut eu non c'est plutôt
une approche de type stasie euh on peut
critiquer les États-Unis avec leurs
patriotes Act et out mais il y a un
certain nombre de contrepouvoirs qui
fonctionnent très bien et notamment de
la société civile on peut citer
l'électronique Frontier Foundation euh
la clu ou autres euh donc c'est pas
parfait mais j'aimerais qu'on ait ce
genre de contrepouvoir on ne l'a pas et
je crains que le l'état d'urgence soit
un alibi euh on prenne justement des des
éléments euh euh factuels pour mettre en
place quelque chose qui qui dit pas son
nom la surveillance de la société faut
command même çair que la loi sur le
renseignement révélé à la dans l'émotion
des attendats de janvier éta en
préparation quand même de il peêre 3 ans
donc il faut faut quand même avoir cette
vision historique moi je suis assez
inquiet d'abord je pense que ça ne
règlera rien là encore on a j' DIRIS
entre guillemets beaucoup de respect
pour les familles qui ont été touché on
a eu affaire à une bande d'amateurs
demain quand ils vont apprendre de leurs
erreurs et qu'ils vont s'enterrer un peu
plus en mode béoin en mode militaire on
ne verra rien c'est donc on pourra
masser des gens derrière des des
ordinateurs c'est une illusion totale
par contre permettre de une surveillance
globale de comment s'appelle de la
population ça c'est intéressant mais
c'est pas il se trouve que la France l'a
fait avec plus de ailes que d'autres
pays mais c'est une tendance générale
d'un certain nombre de pays et ça on a
encore la vision américaine faut
comprendre que nos décideurs sont
paniqués par le changement de la société
ils sont passés d'une société
pompidolienne où on avait des élites qui
parlaient à la masse laquelle prenait ça
comme une vérité révélée un monde
horizontal collaboratif les gens peuvent
vérifier l'information une information
sur Internet elle existe 10 ans après on
peut la croiser c'est que le citoyen
pour qu'il veuillent être intelligent a
les moyens de le rester et de développer
son intelligence collective et ça ça
fait peur à nos dirigeants parce que bon
sens ça veut dire qu'ils ne sont plus c
élite révélé et qu'en gros bah zut le
peuple se met à réfléchir à penser et en
plus à être intelligent alors qu'on
passe notre temps à les prendre pour des
cons donc au bout d'un moment il faut
pas s'étonner que donc c'est pas desvau
bah le problème c'est que le système
voudrait les maintenir avec cet état de
consommateur mais donc on peut faire
confiance un peu aux gens quand même
aussi oui il y a moi je crois la France
a traversé à à traversé des des crifes
très graves elle a une capacité de
résilience ou on est quand même un
tournant où je pense qu'on est en train
d'être anesthésié notamment par ce
modèle américain moi que je hie parce
qu'il est en train de lobotomiser nos
jeunes à la limite nous on fait partie
des vieux qu'on a encore des références
d'avant cette période je suis plus
inquiet pour les jeunes qui qui sont
effectivement dans une qui subissent une
loboisation permanente qu'est-ce que ça
les Américains l'ont compris ils ont dit
les vieux c'est pas la peine de tout
façon ils sont résistants et on n fera
rien ils sont indécrottables travaillons
sur la génération actuelle les jeunes
dans 25 ans voilà faut quand même pas
oublier que beaucoup de nos élites
gouvernementales actuellement en poste
mais du gouvernement précédent ont été
fourmé par exemple dans dans le
mouvement des young American leaders on
peut citer tous nos hommes politiques
sortir la date de promo c'est qu'ils ont
été formé à la pensée
américaine je suis désolé la France
n'est pas condamnée à choisir entre un
bloc ou un autre elle peut être un bloc
en elle-même pierre connais ça l'état
d'urgence c'est les élites amerriican
minded non moi je suis moins je suis
moins critique que vous d'abord parce
que j'ai toujours été amusé par le débat
sur la défense des libertés publiques là
je lisais récemment un article dans le
monde où il y avait un avocat qui
expliquait que les mesures pris contre
les houiganes dans les stades de
football étaient attentatoire aux
liberté donc si tu veux la prof le la
thématique comment dire le défenseur des
droits de l'homme est devenu une
profession à temps plein hein tu as des
gens qui t'interviennent sur tout sur la
loi sur le renseignement on a entendu
mais des conneries mais insondable de
bêtises les types pensaient qu'on allait
écouter la totalité de la population
française c'est le DPI attends attends
laisse-moi finir quand tu as pris le
métro comme moi que tu entends les
conversations que les gens se tiennent
dans le métro tu te dis si les services
de renseignement ils ont autre chose à
[__] ils ont rien d'autre à [__] que
d'écouter ça c'est combien mesurer
combien ça P être non mais maintenant
c'est plus un mec qui avec des écouteurs
comme dans la vie des autres pas ça la
question la question c'est le trait de
l'information tu sais c'est romsfeld qui
disait ça dans une dans truc du Congrès
le renseignement c'est ce que tu sais
que tu sais ce que tu sais que tu sais
pas ce que tu sais pas que tu sais ce
que tu sais pas que tu sais pas alors
une fois que tu as fait ce bilan
critique tu te dis oui les mecs il
avaient une fiche s so what une fois que
tu dis il avait une fiche s la question
c'est qu'est-ce que tu penses qu'il
risque de faire par rapport à la
connexion que tu sais que ce type A avec
tel et telle et telle et telle et telle
mais ça si tu veux c'est parce qu'on vit
tous dans le mirage du film d'espionnage
on pense que James Bond a lui tout seul
connecté avec Sylvester stalon et et
schward zenegger ils vont sauver la
planète tous les jours mais c'est pas
comme ça le travail il est d'une
modestie artisanale et encore une fois
rappelle-toi que dans le cas de cou
Bachi frère Kashi et Koulibali le le le
la DGSI avait un contingent d'écoute
réglementé par une commission
administrative dans lequelle tu avait
certainement un conseiller d'État et un
memre de la cour des compes c'estàdire
des mecs qui ne connaissent rien au
renseignement et donc à chaque fois
qu'il devait changer une écoute ou
éventuellement étendre une écoute genre
sur les femmes des des deux il fallait
qu'il fasse un dossier administratif qui
monte à la commission que la Commission
donne son avis et que ça redescende et
qu' sortte du contingent une écoute bon
quand tu es dans un système comme
celui-là encore une des fois il faut un
peu se tempérer dans la critique de la
loi sur le renseignement parce que sur
le patriote Act il y a des aspects
scandaleux mais qui concerne le rapport
des américains avec le reste du monde
mais les Américains eux-mêmes que je
sache c'est pas devenu une dictature
depuis le patriote Act donc il faut
tempérer la chos faut être ciblé dans
les critiques pas le dire comme si
c'était tout à coup le Big Brother qui
allait commencer si on savait
effectivement écouter tu sais le les
gens pensent qu'effectivement dans le
bureau oval c'est en particulier ce qui
court beaucoup dans Milie arabe on pense
que dans le bureau oval de la Maison
Blanche le mec il décide sur une carte
et que il sait tout sur tout ce n'est
pas vrai c'est pas comme ça que ça se
passe euh monsieur ERC fol vous voulez
rebondir le problème c'est que la loi
renseignement il fallait une loi et ça
je rejoins pierre là-dessus le problème
ce qui me gêne c'est l'absence quasi
totale de de contrepouvoir on est dans
une loi si tu fais des contrôles
administratifs tu te retrouves avec la
viscosité de cette société française
dont on parle prenons l'exemple de
l'acnil dans l'acnil nous avons par
exemple si quelqu'un pense avoir fait
l'objet d'une recherche il y a des
magistrats et je regrette que dans la
sur renseignement les magistrats a été
totalement écartés et si on écoute le
juge trévidique qui est quand même pas
qui quelqu'un de partir intelligent il
est tout aussi critique le problème
c'est que ce magistrat allait voir dans
les fichiers disait monsieur non je ne
peux pas vous dire ce que j'ai vu mais
c'est conforme à l'esprit de l'acnil il
suffisait de faire ce genre de chose moi
ce qui me gêne c'est la précipitation
avec laquel on fait et l'opacité extrême
il n'y a pas eu de débat en tout cas
maintenant il y avait urgence urgence il
y avait nécessité de faire cette loi
voilà maintenant ce qui me gêne plus
c'est que la France est de moins en
moins d'analystes prenons un exemple le
l'Angleterre a a restructuré son
renseignement et elle a environ 1000
analystes en propre c'est d'ailleurs des
gens qui qui travaillent pour l'État en
France nous en avons à peine 200
pourquoi parce que nos services ont
sous-traité certes il y a la la
problématique de captation du
renseignement c'est qu'on capte le
renseignement de mieux en mieux
seulement on a de moins en moins
d'analyse c'est facile de capter des
informations mais quand c'est dans une
langue on comprend pas que ça nécessite
un arrière-plan culturel qu'on ne
comprend plus parce qu'on a viré tous
les spécialistes alors qu'est-ce qu'on
fait et ben la France sraite le
traitement de son renseignement des
sociétés privées le dernier c'était
intelligence notebook qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé intelligence notebook a été
racheté par IBM merde on va quand même
pas faire traiter notre renseignement
par une société américaine je suis pas
sûr qu'intelligence notebook vu son nom
est été française dès le départ
qu'est-ce qui se passe B on va
recommencer de zéro donc 200 analystes
pour la France à peu près 1000 analystes
pour les l'Angleterre
une capacité en propre pour l'Angleterre
en France on va être obligé de sraiter à
des sociétés privées et ce qui me gêne
c'est que la chose régalienne commence à
être traité de plus en plus par des
entités privées
euh je reviens sur l'Angleterre parce
que 1000 analystes c'est très bien mais
tu avais simultanément le londonistance
tu avit les défenseurs de la liberté sur
le thème non non l'Angleterre est une
terre d'asile la liberté de parole pas
question de censurer j'ai assisté à des
prêches à pas corner par des mecs du
Londonistan c'était d'une haine de
racisme de l'antisémitisme absolument
intolérable
ouié nous notre pays alors on tè un peu
sur la thématique de la liberté des
droit de l'homme oui oui et remarque de
vieux con je dirais de ok
Éric on peut mettre TR j'ai dépé la C
aussi que par rapport aux analystes il
en va de même pour le journalisme et les
reporters il faut des mecs de terrain et
il faut être au plus près pour
comprendre parce que le prêche faut être
là pour l'entendre rien que ça c'est
déjà très important Tamam Tamam euh je
vous avez parlé de culture américaine
vous avez parlé de tout ça euh hier il y
a eu un shooting de Mass aux États-Unis
en Californie euh je vais vous passer un
extrait vidéo qui euh je te la chaleur
t'inquiète pas la la on va passer un
extra vidéo d' d'un d'un film qui
s'appelle Rampage 2 Rampage euh et puis
ça vous laissera le temps de boire un
petit coup et puis de regarder c'est à
vous ça c'est chers téléspectateurs sera
peut-être l'unique fois de votre vie où
vous aurez l'occasion d'entendre une
information non censurée ce que j'ai à
vous dire est très important j'ai dû
tuer beaucoup de monde et je serai
moi-même tué pour vous transmettre ce
message j'ai dû prendre la décision de
faire passer votre intérêt avant ma
propre vie je le fais d'abord pour vous
pour que vous vous réveillez et que vous
changiez mais avant de vous dire ce que
j'attends de vous je vais vous donner
les faits et ce sont vraiment les faits
la NSA enregistre tous les coups de fil
les emails les textos sur la terre les
gens comme Snowden ou Assange qui nous
donne les infos nécessaires pour
protéger la démocratie sont traqués et
persécutés par le gouvernement des
États-Unis ce gouvernement a été fondé
par les riches il aime maintenir le
peuple dans le noir dans l'ignorance à
un niveau intellectuel infantile il
s'assure que le peuple est occupé à
faire de l'argent pour survivre qu'il
s'occupe de sa famille de sa maison de
son jardin ils veulent faire croire aux
gens qu'ils sont libres qu'ils ont le
choix de faire ce qu'ils veulent mais
ils ne peuvent pas les personnes qui
vous représentent sont payé pour que
vous restiez dans votre bêtise dans
votre petit monde bien fermé sur
lui-même comment se fait-il qu'il y ait
pas de législation sur les armes à feu
alors qu'il y a un massacre tous les
mois aux États-Unis il y a 11000 morts
par arme à feu tous les ans en
Angleterre seulement 300 pourquoi parce
qu'en
Angleterre ils ont pas d'armes les gens
ne possèdent pas d'armes point
ce que
j'ai fait par le passé et ce que je suis
en train de faire n'est qu'une
conséquence de l'absence de législation
on ne vérifie même pas les antécédents
des clients pour savoir s'ils ont un
passé criminel simplement parce que 50 %
des sénateurs sont payés par les
marchands d'armes alors
réveillez-vous l'assurance maladie
elle bénéficierait à 90 % de la
population américaine pour faire simple
tous les pays développés l'ont déjà et
presque 50 % des Américains sont contre
parce que le lavage de cerveau
médiatique fonctionne à merveille la
guerre en Irak était criminel Bush chîné
et Rumsfeld ont menti aux Nations Unies
et au reste du monde sadame n'avait pas
d'armes de destruction massive et
n'avait rien à voir avec Al-Qaïda nous
savons que nos amis saoudiens ont
financé les attaques du 11 septembre
mais à cause de leur pétrole nous ne
faisons rien contre eux à la place nous
avons envoyé nos soldat se faire tuer
dans des pays qui n'ont rien à voir avec
le terrorisme intérieur pourquoi Obama
n'a pas fait juger le gouvernement Bush
Bush a coûté des centaines de milliards
au contribuables et a commis des crimes
de guerre pourquoi Obama n'a-t-il
entrepris aucune action justice parce
qu'ils sont tous les deux membres du
même club il y a eu plus d'immigrés
renvoyés sous son gouvernement que sous
n'importe quelle autre présidence
pourquoi n'a-t-il pas fermé Guantanamo
où des prisonniers sont enfermés sans
avoir eu droit à aucun procès sans
aucune preuve depuis maintenant 1 ans il
n'a pas mis son véau à
l'approvisionnement des détenus dans le
National Defense authorization Act ce
qui en clair permet la détention infinie
et sans procès américain y compris nous
avons une crise constitutionnelle aux
États-Unis nous avons un état voyou un
état qui viole toutes les lois
internationales qui violent la maniaarta
charte qui définit depuis 800 ans ce que
nous appelons justice Obama devrait être
jugé pour ça il devrait aller en prison
les prisons
justement aux États-Unis nous sommes 5 %
de la population mondiale et nous avons
25 % de la population carcérale mondiale
les gens vont en prison pour 10 g de
cocaïne la moitié des prisonniers est
enfermé pour détention de drogue et la
très grande majorité est noire pour pour
quoi cette situation absurde reste
unchangé je vais vous le dire parce que
Washington reçoit de l'argent du lobby
des prisons pour que ça bouge pas
pourquoi les Popstars les célébrités les
courtiers tous les gens pleins de fric
qui se gaffent de CO et d'exta longueur
de journée vont jamais en prison parce
que quand vous êtes plein auosas vous
êtes au-dessus des lois regardez Lincoln
le film de Spielberg et vous croirez que
la guerre civile a eu lieu pour libérer
les esclaves comme quoi le milliardaire
Spielberg vous rend encore plus bête et
ils feront en sorte de projeter le film
dans les écoles de le diffuser à la télé
en boucle pour toujours mais la vérité
c'est que toutes les guerres ont eu lieu
pour le fric et que le petit peuple doit
crever parce que les élites en ont
décidé ainsi vous regardez la
téléréalité tous les jours pour tuer le
temps et vous croyez que vous êtes à la
page parce que vous regardez Anderson
Cooper et d'autres coquilles vid sans la
moindre opinion l'apparence est sans
importance les marques sont sans
importance les drogues sont sans
importance tout a été créé pour vous
rendreidot la presse libre la télé les
films hollywoodiens l'école l'université
la religion tout ça c'est l'opium du
peuple comme dirait Carl Marx je vais
vous ouvrir les yeux vous réveiller vous
changer je suis sû que jusqu'à un
certain point tu aurais voulu être un
chentre de la vérité pas vrai avant que
tu sois intéressé par le fr par la
télévision je suis sûr que tu aurais
voulu être un vrai
journaliste je suis un vrai
journaliste mais je crois aussi en
l'ordre public et je crois en la
Constitution la Constitution est un
mécanisme de contrôle pour les riches
l'ordre c'est eux ils ont fait la
Constitution pour protéger l'argent et
les terres qu'ils ont volé les riches
n'ont pas à craindre les lois et c'est
partout dans le monde regarde les
oligarques russes et les propriétaires
allemands de l'industrie automobile des
chemins de fer de l'industrie
pharmaceutique ils ont tous utilisé le
travail des esclav whitler pas vrai et
les propriétaires de ces entreprises
sont toujours les mêmes la couronne
britannique pas vrai et les nanti
africains eux ils massacrent leur propre
peuple ils empêchent leur pays de se
développer on lèche le cul des
dirigeants arabes qui viennent avec leur
pétrodollar acheter des voitures de luxe
à nos entreprises américaines pendant
que quotidiennement ils exécutent leurs
prisonniers ils accordent aucun droit
aux femmes ils tuent les Gay seulement
ça on s'en fout royalement parce qu'ils
ont le pognon nos grands patrons ne sont
que des gangsters en costume à rayure
ils se foutent complètement du régime
des lois ils ont mis en place le plus
sophistiqué des systèmes de sécurité
intérieure de l'histoire de l'humanité
ils ont violé les plus basiques de nos
droits constitutionnels et nos libertés
civiles ils ont détourné les ministères
du gouvernement en filial de leurs
propres entreprises ils se sont emparés
du système de contrôle de l'information
pour saturer les ondes de mensonges dont
tu es un bon contributeur chip tu n'es
pas différent des autres journalistes
tous les présentateurs de journaux sont
dans la poche de quelqu'un
alors il nous reste 10 minut je vais
donner la parole à Pierre connais ça
parce qu'il doit nous abandonner dans 10
minutes pierre ben écoute il y a
beaucoup de choses dans ce
film mais qui renvoie autant à nos
propres structures de pensée que la
responsabilité des journalistes le il
cite l'exemple de d'Obama par exemple
c'est vrai qu'on est dans cette
situation extraordinaire où on fait
faire passer des chefs d'État africains
dans la Cour pénale internationale mais
évidemment personne n'a décidé de
prendre mettre un embargo sur les états
à cause de l'invasion de l'Irak on peut
le faire pour Poutine pour l'Ukraine
mais pas pour les États-Unis la
démocratie américaine elle-même a obligé
Clinton à faire des excuses publicque
parce qu'il s'était fait faire une pipe
par une stagiaire mais pas George buouch
qui a déclenché une guerre illégale donc
on est dans ces systèmes là qui acceptte
l'inacceptable ça c'est formidable
deuxième remarque où là je reviens aussi
bien à la responsabilité des
journalistes qu'à la responsabilité des
écrivains
Guantanamo ça s'appelle bon
effectivement c'est arrêter des gens les
mettre sous détention ne pas leur
accorder les droits de la défense pas le
permettre de voir leur famille ni leurs
ni avocats bon dans un autre pays ça
s'appellerait un kidnapping en Colombie
ça s'appellerera un kidnapping en en
Moyen Orient on appellerait ça une un
enlèvement pour islamiste c'est la même
chose mais dans un cas on va expliquer
que c'est un dén de droit dans l'autre
cas on va expliquer que c'est un
kidnapping criminel et dans le troisème
C on va expliquer que c'est les
islamistes pourtant c'est le même
processus donc si tu veux arriver de
temps en temps à remettre la démocratie
selon les mêmes bases de de jugement que
les autres c'est un travail de perpé
interrogation sur la façon dont ces
systèmes fonctionnent parce que la
barrière elle est dans la censure même
dans la tête des gens c'est-à-dire on se
dit oui mais chez nous les droits sont
respectés c'est vrai droits sont
respectés mais effectivement tu prends
le patriote acte tous les droits
américains sont respecter c'est les
droits des autres qui le sont pas
c'està-dire le fait que on peut écouter
la planète entière on peut écouter le
chancelierre allemand on peut écouter C
on peut écouter ça ça ce n'est pas
illégal aux États-Unis alors là où on va
arriver aujourd'hui moi je pense un
exemple qui peut être caucasse les
Saoudiens viennent de lancer on appelle
la candidature pour parce qu'ils veulent
recruter huit bourreaux bon si un jeune
type ce qui lui plaît c'est de décapiter
pourquoi il va partir à l'état islamique
vaut mieux qu'il a en Arabie Saoudite il
peut décapiter légalement d'accord et
donc est-ce qu'il serait pénalement
responsable dans le droit français tu
vois l'ambigué c'est-à-dire est-ce que
le type on va le punir parce qu'il est
allé faire son décapitation légale en
Arabie Saoudite par contre ilillégale à
daesh voilà je suis dans cette dans cet
état d'esprit
éc je suis sûr que c'est bon moi
j'aurais tendance à relativiser ce qui
est vrai ça correspond quand même parce
qu' on parle beaucoup de d'un certain
nombre de de formes de terrorisme il
faut pas oublier qu'en ce moment aux
États-Unis il y a une forme de
terrorisme d'extrême droite très proche
des PE parti très Obama qui est assez
inquiétant qui avec des sabotages
réguliers d'installation électrique
enfin
bref par que l'événement d'hier n'est
que limite la partie visible de ce qui
se passe aux États-Unis il y a une
radicalisation extrêmement inquiétante
notamment dans dans toute la le sud des
États américains maintenant je je pense
que bon on dit la démocratie c'est très
bien mais je pense qu' on peut pas avoir
un État fort une démocratie forte si
elle est pas respectueuse de ses
citoyens et le premier des respect c'est
s'assurer que ce citoyen est capable de
développer un esprit critique et je
reste persuadé que la culture
l'éducation et le maintien de cette
esprit de citoyenneté d'esprit critique
voire de résistance parce que au sens
premier du terme et a été oublié par nos
politique alors c'est je pense que c'est
Al je veux pas dire le premier des CRIM
mais le premier de leur faut euh une
faute grave al certes ça les arrange
peut-être il est plus facile de gérer
des consommateurs que des citoyens mais
je pense que c'est à ce prix là qu'on va
peut-être préserver notre démocratie il
faut pas que ça reste un mot galvodé je
pense que ça se construit tous les jours
moi je me souviens j'avais un je faisais
une intervention à sciencep où un jeune
m'expliquait mais monsieur vous avez
rien compris parce qu'en fin de compte
si nos parents et nos grands-parents on
fait des sacrifices c'est pour qu'on ait
plus à enfire ce jeune là en gros
pensait comme un consommateur ça y est
maintenant je lui dis mais non la
liberté se défend tous les jours vous
aurez à la défendre pour vos parents
pour vos enfants et c'est une chaîne
sans fin donc c'est un combat de tous
les jours il est sûr que si on
lobottimise les gens bah ils vont
raisonner bah je vais profiter du
dernier Apple ou dernier truc maintenant
je peux vivre ça ça n'existe PASF c'est
un mythe donc il faut développer cet
esprit civiqu il faut développer la
culture faut développer l'esprit
critique et la démocratie ne se
retrouvera que grandit parce qu'encore
une fois euh nos hommes politiques ont
besoin d'un peuple intelligent
Hervé précisément euh ce qu'il y a de
redoutable dans ce que tu as montré là
c'est l'absence d'esprit critique
c'est-à-dire
le type parle et il dénonce tous les
mots de la terre parce qu'il en a
l'explication il sait comment ça marche
et donc il donne les clés les clés en
gros c'est le pognon on voit le et et le
côté pourriture mondiale
planétaire à la sortie de ça qu'est-ce
qu'on fait bah on va à l'armurerie du
coin ou ou chez le dealer on prend le
fling et et on
c'est pour moi cette forme
d'appropriation discours de vérité total
qui englobe tout et précisément mon
défi il est en train de me dire si du
cul ouais parce que si jamais toi tu
continues à ne pas reconquérir la
confiance des gens moi j'ai un discours
tout près c'est ça lui c'est mon ennemi
et ça je ne peux pas l'accepter c'est
lui qui me renvoie le défi quotidien
dont parleic dont tu parles et c'est
contre ça que je m'inscris radicalement
pour le coup pour utiliser un mot qui
est très galvodé actuellement et donc
oui il est en train de m'encourager plus
il me hurle dessus et plus moi j'ai
envie effectivement de faire une
information qui est toujours plus
offensive toujours plus incisive
toujours plus aride toujours plus
difficile toujours plus exigeante
pierre je dois te lâcher dans 6 minutes
on va finir l'émission Tous
ensemble je vais vous demander à vous
trois un conseil pour les jeunes
générations une
préconisation ce que vous voulez quoi
vous avez 6 minutes donc ça fait 2
minutes chacun
démerdez-vous
pierre moi je si tu veux je ne je
n'entre pas dans le l'idée d'une espèce
de d'État qui serait un espèce de
monstre un léviatant en perpétuel gain
sur l'espace de liberté des citoyen ce
qui est la caractéristique de la
démocratie c'est que par nature on n'est
pas d'accord c'est-à-dire que la loi sur
le renseignement fasse l'objet de
critique ou qu'il soit l'objet de
défenseur me paraît la le processus sain
de la démocratie que des journalistes
soient accusés comme s'ils étaient les
instruments du pouvoir est un excès de
langage qui suppose qu'on ne connaît pas
le métier qu'on dise tout à coup quand
on n jamais fait de renseignement mais
on a des services de renseignement qui
sont nuls et cetera venant de gens qui
sont des élus politiques si tu veux euh
je me dit bon effectivement c'est comme
si tu demandais de juger un match le
football par un mec qui sait même pas
qui en connaît même pas les règles donc
tous ces processus là ne me gênent pas
euh les on est on est effectivement dans
un système où aujourd'hui je trouve que
la démocratie est contestée par le fait
que notre liberté d'expression est
contestée par des gens qui nient cette
possibilité de la liberté d'expression
c'est ce que disait Woody Allen il
disait la liberté d'expression c'est pas
donner le même temps de parole à Hitler
et une victime de la choix et
aujourd'hui on est piégé par le fait
qu'on a un discours sur la défense des
libertés qui va couvrir également les
salapfhistes j'ai entendu hier a un
débat je sais plus sur quelle radio où
le type expliquait que ça servait à rien
de fermer des mosquées salafistes le
type n'y connaît strictement rien parce
que effectivement c'est quand même un
foyer dans lequel on diffuse une
idéologie mais alors qui elle est
complètement décérébrante au possible et
on va expliquer que les gosses vont en
sortir antisémites vont en sortir avec
l'idée que tous les mécréants peuvent
être massacrés légalement et cetera et
cetera donc il faut faire très attention
avec la thématique de la défense de la
liberté parce qu'on se bat contre un
ventre mou qui est l'état alors qu'il y
a un adversaire qui qui est dur et c'est
sur celui-là qu'il faut focaliser le
regard Éric moi je dirais redevenez
citoyen parce que l'inculture de daesh
ne fait que répondre à la culture
américaine effectivement ce qui me ce
qui me sidère c'est qu'on va vers un
nouvel âge de ténèbres vers lainculture
et je pense que les jeunes doivent se
réapproprier l'histoire doivent
réfléchir doivent voilà redevenir des
citoyens en tout cas c'est la base de la
formation des islamistes parce que ils
réapprennent leur propre histoire
totalement myifiée oui seul coup ils ont
tout un logiciel de défense contre mais
la culture la culture connaître les
autres cultures c'est la culture avec un
grand C c'est-à-dire l'esprit critique
on peut pas faire de culture sans être
critique parce que ce que l'on apprend
il faut déjà le comparer avec d'autres
choses et et la culture comparée en
particulier très intéressante il peut
pas y avoir de pensée unie je veux dire
on oublie que une période très
démocratique c'était quand même la
dynastie des omomeéyad où il y avait les
peuples levanttins é un exemple de
d'harmonie entre différentes religions
parce que c'était des peuples cult
voilà on pourra pas s'en sortir si on ne
revient pas vers cet esprit c'est se
cultiver avoir cet esprit critique et
surtout se comporter en citoyen Hervé
bah donc l'idée c'est tu vois quand même
la différence quand tu sors de ça
qu'est-ce que tu fais tu vas pas chez
Gastine Renet prendre le fling tu prends
l'ordi et tu appuies sur Search et et
tuappuies un max parce que tu confrontes
parce que ce qui est absolument génial
et c'est pour ça que moi je fait
confiance aux temps qui sont ceuxci qui
sont ceux du numérique c'est que la
confrontation des idées elle est là avec
juste un warning écrit si un mec se
présente en disant je vais tout vous
expliquer à ce moment-là tu rappuies sur
Search et tu le zappes c'est la seule
chose que je je je souhaite dire y
compris moi si vous avez le sentiment
que le mec est en train de vous dire
c'est ça la vérité PAP tu changes et tu
surfes pour le plus grand plaisir de
l'intelligence des gens parce que ça
c'est un méga plaisir c'est un grand
plaisir que de se dire tiens il y a ça
tiens il y a ça le plaisir de cette
découverte c'est le plaisir des hommes
et la vérité contradictoire absolument
la culture humaniste exactement vous
arrête plus là ce sera le mot de la fin
je vous souhaite une excellente journée
merci Monsieur merci merci
[Musique]